there is a an ongoing colonialism
happening where people every single day
are killed I cannot keep count this
morning
a kid was shot
in Palestine
we cannot it's embarrassing even for me
that I don't even know the numbers here
but this muzzle has been effective and I
think the only
righteous uh
option itself is to oppose these labels
these smear campaigns that Target us I
myself have been labeled an anti-semite
by the ADL and I mean like if you want
to talk about
the surface level people people say like
wow the ADL until defamation League you
know uh condemned you but people do not
look at the history of the
Anti-Defamation League do not look at
the present of the Anti-Defamation
League the fact that they are
um
the largest non-governmental police
training uh Department in the country
where they train police and
uh racial profiling and militarism the
fact that they have historically and
continue to have engaged in surveillance
on
on Black
Liberation movements on anti-apartheid
South African activists most recently in
Charlottesville when white supremacists
were marching
um and chanting anti-semitic the
ADL advised local police departments to
spy on the Block organizers opposing the
white supremacists this is again all
verifiable on the internet go to
droptheadl.org so if the ADL does not
uh alleviate the uh the hate in the
world
as it probably is designed to do no it's
it's a guys I don't think the apartheid
Defense League is really our most
Progressive but that's what it stands
for yeah okay student no now you know